serge gainsbourg sort un nouveau disque
des champions agressive contre la femme
mais avec le ton d'un homme qui frappé
d'une crise cardiaque il ya quelques
mois prend du recul va à l'essentiel est
fait de sa misogynie plus une attitude
de créer un véritable règlement de
comptes vu de l'extérieur
et là je connais tout ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
j'avais quelques amis j'en aurai un peu
moins jeunes est plus difficile plus
sauvage
de plus en plus mise en trop j'étais
déjà misogyne je te fais la mise en å
uvre être pas grand chose mais il reste
des choses essentielles les enfants
femmes et la création continue avec
l'esprit lucide et les mains qui ne
tremble plus facile
je suis venu te dire que je m'en veux
étonnant époux
pour rien changé
comme dit si bien de rennes trouvant
mauvais
je suis venu te dire
que je m'en veux
tu te souviens des jouets anciens
tu peux
tout
je suppose que tu veux
dit qu'un cheveu
des adieux à jamais
je suis heureux
se dire je m'en veux et l'apport
l'apport de l'alcool et du tabac sur
l'intellect
pour moi c'était très nocif changé
j'étais tellement cette durée que je
restais les nuits entières sans rien
trouver
j'allais assez vite donc j'ai vu le beau
paysage défiler mais j'ai coché un
platane
alors maintenant je sais que j'ai
légèrement blessées au caire va accepter
j'espère que je pourrais survivre
oh
c'est le père et si vite et mon moteur
ceux ci n'ont pas inquiète qui écrivit
en écriture le professeur de lycée moi
j'aime cassez n'est plus et faire des
pâtés tous deux ton post
vu de l'extérieur
bon j'arrête un os bien
ce sont pour mettre un peu plus depuis
il est en stéréo